da sich fortsetzung folgt
[Musik]
heimat ist für familie giessen.de werk
wurde familie die bewirtschaftet da
nämlich in drei stufen betrieb das heißt
familien sich vier mal im jahr um vom
hof zum nächsten das ist anstrengend
aber auch als abwechslungsreiches leben
so katrin richter cr klarheit die
familie zu jahr lang begleitet und
imstande ist ein berührender neblig ist
vorarlberg geboren familie mit allen
höhen und tiefen
seit der film wir von da oben
[Musik]
zum ersten mal sind wir im sommer 2003
auf der alb bei familie gisler
[Musik]
dani der älteste ist 14
der jüngste ist sechs kegel 13 und
tamara das einzige mädchen ist 10
[Applaus]
zu unserem erstaunen treffen wir die
vier kinder alleine an ihre eltern sind
auf ihrem anderen hof anheuern
zwei tage versorgen die kinder die
alpwirtschaft allein
solange die eltern weg sind trägt dani
als ältester die verantwortung
von klein auf sieht sie in die
verschiedenen aufgaben hineingewachsen
sie können fast alles aufkochen
tamara ist gerne eine gastgeberin sie
verpflegt durstige wanderer am liebsten
isst sie alleine auf der alb ohne die
eltern wenn sie selber schalten und
walten kann zum feierabend gibt es einen
wettkampf dani schwingt gegen einen
freund der zu besuch ist daniel und sein
bruder regel haben unter den jungen
schwimmern schon einige preise geholt
der kleine see mit seinen brüdern nach
[Musik]
es sind sommerferien die kinder müssen
nicht ins tal zur schule
für sie ist es die schönste zeit im jahr
[Musik]
die gis wohnen abgeschieden und sind
weitgehend unter sich
sie sind an drei orten zu hause jetzt im
sommer leben sie hier auf der alb auf
2100 metern höhe im frühling und im
herbst wohnen sie 300 meter tiefer in
mayen sees und im winter bohnen sie
unten auf dem hof waldi immer noch fast
700 meter über dem tal die eltern gisler
kommen vom heulen zurück auf die an wert
die gießener hatten drei stufen betrieb
als 29 jähriger bauer übernommen
mutter agnes ist in einem kleineren
bauernbetrieb bei früheren aufgewachsen
und hat früh in den betrieb von bert die
eingeheiratet
die gießener leben von milchkühen der
rinderzucht und vom verkauf von alt
kaeser doch ohne die direktzahlungen
ginge es nicht so viele briefe und ich
berichte waren erwachsen es ist der
letzte tag der sommerferien morgen
beginnt wieder die schule
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die kinder müssen früher aus der
schulweg von der alb runter ins tal
dauert eineinhalb stunden immer weniger
bergbauern betreiben eine stufen
wirtschaft und schon gar nicht so eine
video gisler verteilt auf über 1000
höhenmeter und viermal im jahr umziehen
mit der ganzen familie werden die gisler
kinder dieser berg wirtschaft weiter
führen wollen oder sich lieber für ein
bequemeres leben im tal unten
entscheiden
eine stufen wirtschaft ist anspruchsvoll
die organisation von drei häusern vier
kindern und dem laufenden betrieb ist
anstrengend vieles bleibt am netz hängen
das wirkt auf die beziehung zwischen ihr
und ehemann berti ab problem sind mit
gefühl dass ich mir das vorstelle werde
ich mir später dass sie das geschafft
zwei jahre später treffen wir die gis
las wieder
es ist herbst und sie ziehen von der alb
300 meter runter ins meyers es im alten
haus müssen sie sich jedes mal wieder an
die enge gewöhnen
dani ist im sommer mit der schule fertig
er wird in der sägerei eine lehre
anfangen
dies macht sich auch gedanken über ihre
zukunft
es ergibt sich eine möglichkeit oberhalb
von ihrem einsatz soll ein alten kiosk
für wanderer entstehen agnes möchte den
kinos brachten dann wäre sie finanziell
nicht nur vom hof abhängig
dann packen sie die sachen um noch vor
dem großen schnee in den hof waldi
runterzuziehen
[Musik]
hier unten in ihrem winterquartier im
val de sieht das leben anders aus
[Musik]
wir fragen ob sie später einmal in die
fußstapfen ihrer eltern treten möchte
[Musik]
dani und regel verschwänden noch keine
gedanken an ihre zukunft
[Musik]
sie sind wir eigentlich und das ist
schön wenn sie so was man von einem
händler
[Musik]
sieben jahre später im frühsommer 2012
treffen wir die gisler buben wieder wie
jedes jahr um diese zeit treiben sie ihr
viel hoch auf die an dran ist inzwischen
23 sein bruder regel 22 und sie ist 15
auf der alb sind sie nur noch selten
aber immer noch gern an und machen die
freiheiten sind weniger geworden die
gisler kinder wohnen unten auf dem hof
waldi von hier aus fahren sie täglich
ins tal zur arbeit und semi zur schule
dani hat die lehre in der sägerei und
regel in der schreinerei abgeschlossen
sie arbeiten jetzt beide bei merkel in
der baufirma sie haben flexible
arbeitszeiten und können jederzeit auf
dem familienhof mithelfen
tamara macht eine lehre als bäckerin
konditorin flachland strange beast
[Musik]
berti gisler führt die drei stufen
wirtschaft so weiter wie bisher
jetzt im frühling versorgte das vieh auf
den weiden sees und sie hat turbulente
zeiten hinter sich
sie packte den alpen kiosk wie sie es
sich gewünscht hatte und führte ihn als
eigenes unternehmen
vier jahre lang bis es hier zu viel
wurde mit dem kiosk und dem
familienbetrieb
sie gab den kiosk auf heute hilft sie ab
und zu noch aus in ihrer ehe spitzte
sich vieles zu was sie immer wieder
angesprochen und belastet hatte sie fand
eine arbeit im tal und zog von zu hause
aus die überlastung und die differenzen
in ihrer beziehung wissen sie ihr leben
von grund auf ändern
das sind aufgaben sind gefährdet sind
so bringt sie machen das sehr gut und
ich kann mir aber ich finde
das ist ja so dass dank der bank so
gemacht das ist das wunder dass die
letzten jahre waren schwierig für die
ganze familie
es fehlt die jungen geben alles obwohl
sie ihre jobs im tal haben soll der
betrieb so weiterlaufen wie bisher
für daniel ist es eine doppelbelastung
nicht langweilig werden die module
siegten die forschung verschafft sondern
aber spricht fotos oft vermischt locker
mal hier was ich habe mich schlagen
wollen
wie soll es mit dem betrieb weitergehen
ihrem familienunternehmen das allen sehr
am herzen liegt da wie voltaire immer
maurer werden regel bauer wird einer von
ihnen den hof ganz übernehmen
agnes hat geburtstag
es ist nicht selbstverständlich mit
ihrer familie am küchentisch im walde zu
sitzen wo alles noch so scheint wie
früher fast wie früher ein paar neue
gesichter sind dabei
miriam die freundin von dannen eine
bauerntochter aus dem appenzell
patrick ist der freund von tamara er ist
ebenfalls baum semi und party kommen
später von einem jungschwinger wettkampf
zurück
[Musik]
die schulzimmer hinter einem liegen
agnes arbeitet seit einem jahr im
verkauf gleichzeitig hat sie eine
massage ausbildung gemacht irgendwie
aber ist sie immer noch auf der suche
nach dem richtigen kraft
dani und regel sind unterwegs im
untertal sie verkaufen einrennt
es erwartet sie ein unerlaubtes
zusatzgeschäft ein kälbchen steht zum
verkauf
viehzucht ist von klein auf ihrer
leidenschaft und sie wissen genau worauf
es ankommt
es gibt wieder mit dem 22
[Musik]
zur verhandlung kommt der vater dazu
kamera hat die lehr und abschlussprüfung
der lehrmeister beurteilt ihre
prüfungsarbeiten sie hat bestanden nun
ist sie unabhängig
ein neuer lebensabschnitt beginnt dani
ist die größte stütze seines vaters er
fühlt sich immer mehr für den hof
verantwortlich schritt für schritt
steigt er nun doch in den betrieb ein
für berti ist es eine große
erleichterung dass dani den hof
übernehmen will
er lernt nun loszulassen und gönnt sich
wieder mehr zeit für seine andere
leidenschaft
die musik
[Musik]
dani scheint sein glück gefunden zu
haben
seine freundin miriam mack hilft immer
mehr auf dem hof nicht wieder einfach
was man ganz so etwas finde das glaubt
mitmacht aber nicht
es kommt wie es muss
werden berge und agnes ihr glück finden
wird miriam mit granit zusammen die
familientradition weiterführen
fest steht dass der hof auf dani
überschrieben hat die gisler sind sich
alle einig sie werden heimkommen und
dani helfen wann immer er sie braucht
und auf der alb sein wie sie mit seinen
freunden so oft sie können
ganz so wie es die bergbauernfamilie
immer gewohnt war
[Musik]
david slade die begegnung mit der
bergführer familie kuffler wirtschaft
der vater bert innenhof sondern in einer
schlosserei in sedo hat sich vieles
verändert wieder bei ihrer familie
ritter letzten frühjahr wie sie hitlers
das windows casino wieder bergbahnen
abgemacht
[Musik]
und doch
doch sehr wundern was bei dir und deiner
familie profi sieht eine letzte doch was
hat sich verändert
ich habe einige sagen welcher besonderes
ja und meine gedanken sich persönliches
ja aber zwei jahre noch besonders
entschlossen so lukrativ der betrieb
sicher intensiviert und es ja also ich
werde jugend machte ich mich nicht so
einfach ja
das ganze klingt jetzt wie soll man dann
auch bemerkt haben dass meine musik
kamen 14
[Musik]
am wochende herbert zwei die arbeit die
er für die hoch über nebelgrenze
[Musik]
es ist der alte kiosk und agnes beachtet
er liegt direkt über gsm lieblingsort
von berti
die gegend orangen beliebten ausflugsort
für schneeschuhläufer
[Musik]
sie zwei jahre führte den kiosk und 22
als spezialität des hauses vollgelaufen
familie begleitet ist das macht mich
einfach manchmal hilft stellt sind
wiederum gab und das wird mir sagen hat
was wird und trieb freitag herrscht und
reichlich
sonst ist das match dichter betrifft und
und technischen vertrieb wird sich zum
betrieb von it betrieb
jetzt mitmachen und haben
mit den druck gewehrt die neue levels
privat immer noch trennt die weg aber
schaffen es fertig seid treffen
rumänische im gebiet in dem kiosk
einfachen schneeschuhe wegner
das schafft im betrieb oder lokaler
seilbahn und ich im winter für
sicherheit wurde schneeschuhe bike
verantworten
[Musik]
du musst dich
und dabei ein tag in der woche hilft sie
an berti im kiosk
[Musik]
der krieg wird jetzt der bärte aber du
schaaf steht ja immer noch das gute so
dass die mannschaft mit und ja das kommt
sehr gut ja also für mich und dann reden
momentan ist noch mal drüber whisky ist
wo sie als print familie und der hoheit
also ich kann mir vorstellen auch so
wäre wäre der fläche qualen schafft und
ein halt ist so ihm nach wie vor rechnet
zeit verständlich dass irgendeine frau
sagt für mich stimmt und also so gut
dass irgendwie niemals bereut das macht
für mich begleitete jetzt macht es wenn
du jetzt den betrieb übernommen hat mit
seiner freundin über leistung eigentlich
was ist das für sie votieren
so wie sie sind ja irgendwo mal sieht
man hat angefangen hätte irgendwo also
ich wozu sicherlich lee bewusster machen
irgendwie schaffe schaffe das hat
zugestimmt dass das nicht stimmen
ich freue mich mit bewusst jetzt
bewusster fall aber ich nehme mich da
kann ich nicht sagen einen schnitt
gemacht haben
iris als familie also meine gene sind
jetzt eigentlich die meisten sind
erwachsen wie eigentlich steckt und
dagmar sind wirklich sehr gut haben und
ja also ich danke
dass sie andere umgang der medien und
dankbar dass ich das gemacht dass sie
das weil kennt die problematik kommt
dass wir das licht angemacht
trotz aller veränderungen dezember hat
bewies wie stark bleiben und alle
unterstütze benannt
agnese und dabei die welt diesen beiden
wir streben oktober
morgen steigt für dani und tamara und
dresden
das sind alt nach im kanton obwalden
gute halbe stunde verkehrsbetriebe weg
da lebt tamara sie geschrieben mit ihrem
flachland ihren freund der patrick
bühler hat inzwischen der hof was im
kino wäre pure und jetzt deutliche
spuren auf
es gibt dann immer dahin wo man sich
einfach selbst widerruf tamara hilft
ihrem freund ihrer freizeit
ich mache handelsrelevante hat mich
braucht bin ich da eigentlich los war
als 100 prozent ihrer kraft der wert
bezieht haben auch einfach mal schwarz
mal wieder so zu verkaufen ist es viele
regeln also pure also suche installieren
so aufstellen dass ich sie haben das
land und das schlimme machen mit
kollegen
du wirst mir die blogs sowie der kuchen
wurde tamara und den bau trick 35
christian der brüder von der tamara
bischof versuch christian seifert auf
dem bauernhof ganz energie nicht wieder
wachsen heute nach fünf minuten entweder
schaffen
naja wie heidi auf widerruf gewachsen
sind prägt
ja danke sagt aber dass die art wie sie
aufgewachsen ist es positiv dass die den
vertrieb schlimmer so schnell mal war
ich 25 jahre und noch das brot die väter
bisschen erschrocken schon immer weiß ja
was jetzt ernst machen wie du irgendwas
problem auf dichter und anstatt dass die
videos studiert ja auch irgendwie habe
ich das gefühl ich hatte das gefühl dass
ich jetzt eigentlich nur dazu das
treffen wie viel wasser das ganze
familie in der nacht ständig eigentlich
meine 20 der älteste kieslaster dani ich
auf dem hof war die grafik spaziergang
14-malige spazieren
zwischen ihnen und ich hoffe es ist so
der daniel für trainer mit seiner
freundin miriam ob sie zwei jahren
betrieb immer noch mit alb und muss es
wie schon viel druck machten
was neu ist seit nachwuchs g4 monats ist
doch linie levin mit weltruhm
die meisten arbeiten machen es
miteinander auf der alp bora ist miriam
fischer zuständig der daniel v
er züchtet erfolgreich ist dir dass du
gerne
überhaupt ist ja sich ein großes ding
ein extremer eine gute nachricht für den
sektor der ruster punkt aber auch daran
dass wir sind relativ flexibel in china
hat die größte chance haben der
innenraum wurde jahren
und diese ganzen stall um sex und macht
mich das stolz ist ins minus auf dem
betrieb sie gehen nur städten dann
überhaupt über dem meer sind relativ
hoch
die jungen spüren und die junge männer
sagen sie wird übernimmt den betrieb und
dann wurde entscheid fällten die
freundin miriam ich frage mich ja der
oder sagte sie habe ich dass sie meine
zerschnitt die neue tochter kaufen
bücher betrieb sind extrem
das ist boxen ist ja richtig was man
isst
[Musik]
dani ist es wichtig dass miriam zieht
für sich hat und nun auf dem hof
schaffen wie sie die mur tragen nun auf
der bucher betrieb bleibt hat miriam ist
sattlerin unter dani hat ihre nase
branche als autowerkstatt baut also
brasilien verschaffen sollte ja also ja
das wär bestätigung also bestätigen
einfach kultur für dich selber das heißt
aber du gelernt hast dass du danach
rasch wieder schaffen
der tsi motor von landesseite der hexe
viel zu wenig gemacht ist dass wir die
räume sowie sb spielverzögerung
dann ist er prägt vor dem und er will
sicher nicht das meer oder dass sich das
amazon machenschaften aber lockt
sicherte sich für die sache macht
da sind immer für die mannschaft oder
für den betrieb mit reha und ich sage
danke ich glaube es gibt nicht so meine
frau mit dem auto sondern großen so also
sicher ziemlich viele ist auch klar wie
oder also sicher gibt es manchmal moment
frau mehr zeit dem wetter und so wird
jetzt mit dem sommer denken sommershow
nicht immer einfach ist oder du bist
immer ja wir unterwegs dann gestorben
aber es gibt also sehr heftigste mit
mitarbeiter
und ein renner die zwei jüngsten vom
fußball die das semi geßler hätte leben
können
[Musik]
sie macht alles gibst du wohnst begann
ja nicht wirklich angekommen und das
bild wenn jemand vergisst wurde
empfehlen wir steht wie du mit deinem
hund geschwungen als maximal ring mit po
box sie schwingen das thema
links im bild
mainz wegen einer landwirtschaft
[Musik]
und dann gibt's neues familienmitglied
wo man in einer bergtour familie
erwartet
der ev zug ist also das ziel der
tradition die partei will aber sicher
weniger rosig war es freilich höher
bewertet bei jedem jederzeit aus dem max
kurven scorte
aber es gibt tage wo es einfach prüft
jetzt ein hersteller sieht anders aus so
green economy ist auch einer der ducati
worden sind nicht ergriffen oder um es
mit der er in der zellerau operation zum
ganze familie aufwachsen als
vorsichtsmaßnahme
ja aber es ist erst das volumen
fortsetzung folgt der dani geht ihm
schon wieder was er selber erlebt hat
viel abwechslung streiks in den langen
schulenberg
wenn denn dorf meyer sei es der schnee
schmilzt für die lewins lieber als
bergführer boule-bahn ganzes sowie das
geht los im schalker tor gemacht hat
[Musik]
merck suche geschickt wo eine
fortsetzung dieses wunders zwei frauen
wo krämpfe dass sich entwickler web
der herr worten gegen politisches
phänomen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
einfach mal laufen wieder rennen schon
immer gemacht zum weiterleben als
spender organ viele sport1 es geschafft
fortsetzung folgt in einer woche